good morning believe nation today's
message is to be consistent be
consistent be consistent be consistent
be consistent be consistent be
consistent be consistent be consistent
be consistent be consistent be
consistent watch this clip from Ali code
n goat a human must be consistent when
you try a business and you stat you
might have hiccups here and there but it
does not mean that that business is not
going to work there must be challenges
in fact what I keep saying is that life
without challenges is very very boring
so if you have challenges you just have
to know how to work out or how to walk
around these challenges and you will be
successful once you are consistent what
business does it like is for you to try
something and then once you have one or
two problems and I want to change and
move into another business that doesn't
walk in business so this guy gets it and
there's a reason why he's a billionaire
most entrepreneurs they're not
consistent because it's hard because you
fall off the tracks because something
happens in your personal life or you're
not seeing the momentum you want or you
get distracted or you have entrepreneur
EDD you want to jump to another project
and you may be consistent for a week or
a month or a couple months and then you
fall off the tracks and you can't get
back on most entrepreneurs give up too
soon and you have to realize that even
if you're only a part-time entrepreneur
you need to dedicate time every single
day to growing your idea and making your
dreams happen and not get bogged down by
excuses and allowing life to get in the
way you know if your grandparents get
sick you're still spending time on your
business if you're going through a
divorce you're still spending time on
your business if you get massively sick
and you can't speak and you're lying in
bed you still spend time on your
business all of those things happen to
me and myself spend time on my business
and it grew you have to make sure that
every single day you're being consistent
and following through on your company I
want to share a quick story from the
agency that I'm with so it's been two
years since I've been with my agent and
when I first started there he told me
that he loved my platform he loved my
message but he didn't love how I was on
YouTube he felt like it could be way
stronger on YouTube so I told great
was the number-one person on your agency
what is a YouTube channel and I'm gonna
beat them and so he showed me who it was
and at the time that person's getting
three times the number of new
subscribers that I was three times and I
said fine I'm gonna beat him and I
started being consistent and every day I
released videos and then bumped it up to
two videos every single day I was doing
two videos if I'm on vacation if I'm
sick if something's happened in my
personal life if I'm at a conference I'm
still releasing two videos every single
day I was consistent and here's what
happened
it took me 22 months to catch him 22
months of slow growth slow painful
painful growth I'm feeling like I'm
putting everything I have into these
videos I'm throwing energy I'm doing
research I'm spending the time on it I'm
like why am I not getting results faster
right and I'm pouring everything I got
into it 22 months to catch him and at
the 22nd month I beat him by one percent
and that was that was happiness you know
here it was I achieved my goal but I
wanted it to be consistent one month
isn't enough the 23rd month I'd beaten
by 10% now we have a trend going 24th
month that's this month right now I'm on
track to almost double where he's gone
so it took me 22 months just to catch
him the 22nd months with just catching
him 23rd month was 10% above and 24th
month is almost a hundred percent above
and that's what happens at a lot of
times with your business you've seen
tiny tiny tiny tiny tiny growth and then
boom it takes off because you allow for
momentum to build because you are
consistently creating awesome work in
your business but how many of you are
willing to spend that time how many of
you are willing to spend the effort to
put into your business every single day
and see minimal results because that's
what it takes and that's a typical
progress it's slow slow slow slow slow
slow sometimes four years and then it
takes off you got to believe in what
you're doing you got to love it you got
to know you can have an impact and you
got to be consistent in adding value to
your business every
Ingle day believe my question of the day
for you today is what do you do
consistently in your business and if
you're not what's holding you back
share it in the comments below I want to
see what you have to say thank you guys
so much for watching have a fantastic
day continue to believe and I'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot
of espresso